hey everybody welcome back to fantasy
belly in this video I'm starting work on
a small waterfronts for the lake in the
middle of the park and one side of the
Main Street because I'm going to try to
do the Main Street as quickly as I can
which doesn't mean that I'll be cutting
any corners on the building's themselves
it just means that I won't be recording
everything and I'll have quite a few
parts of the making of it left out of
the videos just to save time for that
I'm just kind of afraid of having the
entire making of this slow me down even
more because I do hope to get into the
rest of the park as soon as I can
and also well I was kind of afraid of
having so many Main Street videos just
because a Main Street does take quite a
lot of time to get all of the buildings
in so yeah we're just going to do it in
two episodes cut out what I can to get
that done and after that we're going to
head into the rest of the park that's
basically the plan but before I get into
that I still wanted to make a quick
water form here just to see what this
would really look like I was actually
planning this out for an entire evening
and seeing what I wanted to do with the
lake and that didn't really turn into
anything so we're just coming up with
stuff as we go along here and the first
thing that I just well randomly popped
into my head was the head like a whole
circle around at the end of the Main
Street where you can get pretty close to
the water with like some steps that
bring you down there and a nice fence
which will eventually give a cue
straight into the big Rini of the park
which is going to be like a big mountain
with castles or something like that on
top of it anyway this is like a nice
viewing point to get very close to the
lake and just kind of see what the rest
of the park looks like so that's what I
wanted to do here and it's a bit of an
experiment with what I wouldn't really
call in an experiment but it's a bit of
a like trial and error process with the
parts there to try and get a part
looking thing in there because there
those things are not actually passed and
I am aware that you can have passed like
over hang by the water by having them
levitate but it just means that you're
well really limited to the way that the
past is
works which isn't all that flexible and
I really wanted to be like quite precise
and perfectionistic about how this
entire waterfront is set up with the
stairs and with planters between the
stairs and the only way to really do it
in a sense where you have control over
every single thing and the shape and
look how everything on the waterfront
would be to just make the entire thing
myself and have fake pots around it and
I don't think I'll ever have real parts
underneath this I could actually do that
and just have the parts go underneath
them because they are pretty close to
the ground but especially in this stairs
it wouldn't really look all that great
and people would have their feet go
straight through stairs and just
altogether it's not really a great thing
so I ended up just having this thing at
least for now just be a decoration and
not actually a functional water phone
the rest of these parts though are
pretty much going to be all functional
as you can see and they're going to be
like the main sort of hub for the path
system in the rest of the park so the
pots around here are pretty important
it's just that little dip lowering next
to the lake that the guests won't be
able to go to but they are basic sort of
build up to it is just that half circle
and the rest of the parts was just a bit
of trial and error just kind of see what
the in-game path system would give me
until I felt something that was quite
nice and that's why I ended up with here
and finally I was looking at that like
whites thing in the middle of the park
here which you can't get rid of because
that's just the way that parts connect
but um I was actually figuring for a
while I could place a nice centerpiece
in here and I was trying to get like a
pillar with something on top of it but
there are a couple of problems with an
idea one is that it would just block the
view of what's behind it and the other
is that there isn't really any fitting
kind of a statue to put on top of it so
the idea that I went with in the end is
to just put a fountain in here which
means that it can stay quite low which
means that you can still see whatever is
behind it
which goes two ways like from the other
the other side of the lake
still be able to see the entrance
building and the main street and
everything and from the Main Street
you can still see like a castle which is
gonna appear in the distance so that's
quite good and also fountains are just
really cool to make so that is now a
fountain I actually had a lot of fun
with that sort of metal piece which I
didn't talk about before but um I think
I mentioned it in yeah I think it was
episode 2 where I mentioned that sort of
sign with the ironwork on the side which
I figured could be used for fences and
it's a really beautiful and versatile
piece I think since it just has that
that black part of it which is the
ironwork stick out so you can make so
many of these ironwork kind of things
with them so they work really well for
fences I think but something like this
where you just want to have some sort of
iron detailing around it it works as
well so I'm quite happy with how that
thing well really sort of puts the iron
work into place wherever you want to and
there's definitely other elements of
like objects that you can sink it to the
ground or sink into other objects to get
like the small point that you want to
have but I'm going to try to do that not
that much in this park since it's
already starting to slow down my
framerate and I have barely even started
yet on the park but yeah one of those
other ways in which I kind of wanted to
mix some pieces together to make new
stuff was for the lights on the
waterfront here and I totally stole the
idea to use the chimneys as pillars for
the fence here from ku kimono which I
think he was using the same chimneys I
can't remember which chimneys he was
using but he was using some chimneys
alongside a waterfront with some torches
on top of it and I thought that looks
amazing just like pretty much everything
else he does so we're gonna go with an
idea and now that I've mentioned him I
should really just give him a proper
shout out if you haven't yet and you're
into like planet coaster design park
stuff you should really check out Cooke
I'm on this channel it is some amazing
stuff with this game but um yeah that
was basically the waterfront that I
needed and the rest of this video will
be all about one side of the Main Street
and the first building that I started on
which is by far the most
well in a way interesting building but
definitely the most important building
on the Main Street is the corner
building just because it's such a
visible building and it has that thing
on the corner which sticks out and give
it gives it like some sort of shape and
for this building I wanted to go with a
dome because I haven't made a dome in
this game or in alpha-3 before and there
are all sorts of new pieces which you
can use very nicely to make domes in all
sorts of colors and textures that you
want to so for this building we're gonna
go for a pretty tall dome actually which
is gonna be black because the walls are
quite white and all of the accents on
this building are gonna be very light as
well so I wanted to get a dark roof in
there and it just took a bit of like a
bit of puzzling to see what pieces would
work best for the dome I built like a
very quick test dome before I went into
the real deal here and that's why I
settled with some of these specific
pieces here just because they have a
general texture like all of the castle
pieces even if they have different
shapes they have a very similar texture
which means that they all fit quite
nicely together and I ended up just
putting a few small wooden things at the
top because they're the only things that
are small enough to really make it all
the way to the top of the dome to finish
it but um it's also black so I think it
fits in quite nicely and just finishing
off one more side here because it is a
dome within one building I had to make
sure that it would be doable within the
grid like usually I would like to make
just one side of the dome even if it is
an eight sided dome and just copy that
over but since this is all pipe of the
same building which makes it a bit
easier because it's a bit more
controllable and it's always centered
but on the other hand it also does make
it a bit less easy since I had to make
two sides but yeah just copying that
around should finish the dome which is
the one thing which I like my doing
domes or custom towers in a sense is
that they're quite easy to make if you
just make one side of it and copy that
to the other sides so yeah the dome was
actually the least work of this entire
thing most of the work went into
of experimenting and seeing that the
different pieces would look like on each
other to make those more classical
looking windows and doors in this case
so that took a bit of looking at all the
pieces and seeing how it would look and
the same that goes for Windows or that
goes for domes and towers obviously also
goes for the windows and all of the
details that you put on top of it just
make one side and copy that around and
you'll be able to save a lot of time and
however even when for like the white top
part that I have on top of the domes is
the kind of transition into that golden
peak that I have on the very top of the
dome adding some parrots slightly sunken
into the roof here to have that white
transition which also took a bit of like
very specific placement until I had it
in a place where I really liked it but
this is basically what I ended up with
it almost kind of looks like a volcano
in a way without the the golden pine on
top of it but um that's just a bit of I
suppose art nouveau riche kind of weird
white stuff all over the dome don't take
that too out of context please
but um yeah copying over the second
point which sometimes I think it's also
easier to just select almost the entire
building and take out the page take
other parts which you don't need instead
of very selectively selecting the parts
which you do need because in most cases
it's easier to get rid of the pieces
that you don't need after you've copied
it so that's one thing which I always
like to do to save a bit of time now
onto the rest of the building just the
windows and the doors on the bottom
floors these are going to be quite
simple and quite similar as well and
there's a very simple color scheme to
this building as well which is one that
I might actually revisit at some point
in the future because it is a bit more
simple and straightforward than the
other colour schemes on the buildings
it's just white walls which more or less
always works with this kind of thing the
accents are just kind of beige-ish
to at least have a slightly different
colour from the white walls to stick out
a little bit but it's definitely not too
contrasting
the roof is obviously blank and then the
rest of the windows are kind of wooden
so they have that just standard
brown-ish wooden color to it the one
thing that I'm not too sure about in
this building in hindsight is that it is
quite colourless pair to many of the
other buildings in the park so that's
one reason why I might get back to this
and see if I can add some more color to
it this is not really the final shape
with the building and the way that it's
going to look
eventually when it's finished at least
in terms of how all the details are made
and how they laid out and one other
quick walk work that I wanted to do with
this building is that it is quite a Main
Street USA looking building I figured
and I also wanted to take that quick
sort of forced perspective trick from
the Main Street
in its so the windows on the bottom
floor are a bit taller than the windows
on the higher floors and the windows on
the dome itself are just about the same
height but they just help kind of bring
out the dome a bit more and just by
having that like bottom floor be a bit
taller than the higher floors
it makes the building look a little bit
taller than it is which in this case is
quite nice but um yeah it is actually
quite a it would actually fit in quite
nicely I think in Main Street USA
it was mostly inspired by the buildings
in Fantasia Allen's Main Street even
though it is definitely not referenced
from any particular one of them it does
have the same sort of atmosphere to it I
think but um yeah it's one of the most
Main Street looking buildings in the
entire Main Street because many of the
other buildings are going to slant more
towards channel Alpine or just very
fantasy or many of them are going to end
up being very castle like buildings now
the roof of this building is going to be
very simple as well it's just really one
of those very steep straight Main Street
buildings and it'll be lined with
dormers along all of the places where
the regular
those are so you have that straight line
everywhere I'm not really a fan of
seeing dormers that are like placed
differently than the rest of the windows
on the building on buildings like this
like you always just see them in one
straight line which is just a very
simple and basic straightforward
approach for this building and those
dormers more or less finish of the
building with some slightly different
windows because there was a lot of the
same window on the building but yeah
that is just about it for the building
itself now I wanted to finish off a bit
on the sides as well this building will
also eventually have just a create box
on the end of it with AC units and edged
facts and all that good backstage stuff
but at least I needed to finish that on
the side to be able to get that in and a
few final planters and lanters lanterns
damnit I should actually finish it off
and make it look a bit more alive and
that's basically it for this building
and now we're gonna get into a pretty
big-time skip here where you can see
that I've added these couple of
buildings on the side which I didn't
have before
I was actually live-streaming this for a
bit which was quite handy to save a
little time on the time-lapse err much
of the time here was just kind of spent
seeing how I wanted to like compose
these buildings on the Main Street and
they're all slightly slanted which was
an idea from shadow in the twitch
channel which was a really awesome idea
which helped out in the end just make
the Main Street look a bit more dynamic
and interesting and yeah the basic
approach is just have all the buildings
have sort of the same height just some
slight differences in there and they
also have sort of the same basic shape
to it but they all have slightly
different styles and different things on
them now this building that I'm working
on here is particularly interesting
though I think that was just an L too
many because it has that Tower on the
side and the reason why I wanted to get
that is that you have this very small
sort of mini plaza as you come out of
the tower because I needed that sort of
mini Palace because I didn't want
the entire main street to be like the
same width as it has at the end of it
but also I needed to get the building's
actually connects to the entrance
building properly and the entrance
building is a super wide building so I
have that small Plaza and I figured why
not put a tower on the corner building
here and really make this look like a
real corner building and the other
advantage that having that sort of
corner tower here has is that if you
look from the other direction say if you
look from the lake you can actually see
this sort of like building up bunch of
towers from the main street like you
just don't see this straight facade that
most of the Main Street is made out of
but you see these bunch of towers I kind
of just stack into the distance with the
two biggest towers of the gates of the
entire park in the very end and I'm not
really sure if this makes any sense
as I say it right now but it will
probably make sense once I get into the
next video and you'll see the entire
Main Street image in its finished States
and you can see all of the towers as you
look at it from the lake which I think
looks pretty cool so yeah we're getting
a tower in here and aside from that this
is a really a bit of a combination
between just the town how its kind of
thing and a very castle type of building
so it definitely has some of the console
elements but in general I think it could
fit into the Main Street very well it's
mostly the towers on the side of course
that make it like look like such a
castle building and I will be putting
some facilities into many of these
buildings by the way but it's just
something that I was thinking of after I
built the building already like I don't
build these buildings with sort of the
facility that they're going to be in
mind so never I'm never really thinking
right this is going to be the toilet
building and we're going to make it look
like a toilet building it's just more or
less built the building's first and then
see what kind of facilities we still
need to get in and see what buildings
those facilities fit best in and I can't
actually remember what some of these
buildings are but I think I got two
facilities in
on this side of the Main Street and it's
going to be a bit more on the other side
I just want to get everything I can into
the Main Street
anyway I completely forgot to say that
we're getting into a new building here
this is going to be the final building
off this side of the Main Street and
it's a very small Alpine building it
really felt like the only building that
I could really fit in here but also you
have like two very stone heavy buildings
on both sides and it felt like a more
wooden building with some more rustic
details on it would work quite nicely
over here and also it's just such a very
narrow plot this was just about the only
thing that I could come up with that
would look like an awkwardly squished
building in between two giants and I
think yeah I just placed the toilet sign
but this is going to be the first aitt
building just because it's a very small
building that doesn't really stick out
too much and it seems like a building
where a more sort of backstage kind of
facility like that would be so we are
having the first aid in this building
and all of these will be connecting to
the main path in the middle by the way
I've gotten a few comments about whether
I'll actually have functional parts
running like underneath the gray
concrete that I have on the side here
which is the thing that I might get into
I can definitely do that since the roofs
that make up the like sort of
make-believe paths they are quite low so
you won't have any peeps clip through
them too much but I still have to figure
out like how and if I'm gonna have parts
run underneath that for people to walk
over because I'm still going to be
placing some planters and some lights
and things like that over all of these
paths so if I do want to have functional
parts underneath it I'm gonna have to
place those first and figure out if I
can sort of see exact those in between
for now though the only places where
people will be walking of the grey areas
here is to get into the facilities as
you can see very app very quickly adding
that part in there but that's basically
all of the buildings finished now the
last thing that I wanted to do is just
add some of those more little details
and whatever you can really add on the
side of the street here so a bunch of
trees with planters and a few flower
pots as well and just your standard kind
of path elements will come too so
there'll be a few little bins and some
extra window boxes and um well lots of
pots and barrels everywhere just to add
a bit of extra detail but it's nothing
big really just that little bit of extra
looking aliveness after all of the
buildings are already finished and this
is a hat shop so that's pretty good
actually think that fits in quite nicely
so we have the hats fantastic in this
building and that basically finishes off
the main street that is just about it
for this time-lapse I have nothing else
to show you guys but I do have two more
clips of what this looks like in the end
so I'm gonna close off the video with
that thank you guys for watching and I
hope to see you guys next time
[Music]